en fait je vous explique à ce moment là
quand j'ai vu cette interview il ya des
blogueurs qui ont commencé à dire c'est
peut-être y lan
sk ne vous a jamais city alma jamais
citer mais elle a quand même bien fait
comprendre
plus ou moins de qui on parlait il ya un
blogueur qui a commencé à à dire je
pense que c'est ilan des gens ont
commencé à m'envoyer des insultes des
messages d d d horreur dont je suis allé
voir alix en message privé jeudi indique
ce parce qu'on se connaissait et les
mois de très longtemps je dis ce que tu
peux faire un démenti sur le fait que tu
ne parles pas de moi s'il te plaît parce
que je commence à me faire insulter et
prendre un bad buzz alors que c'est pas
mérité
et alice m'a répondu je parle de toi
ilan
d'accord
ok très bien
du coup c'est pour ça que je me suis
senti visé sauf qu'aujourd'hui cette
conversation je vais pas rendu public
parce que j'ai pas le droit de le faire
tout simplement
et comme je me suis sentie visée
c'est normal que j'ai commencé à vouloir
me justifier parce que je recevais des
insultes parce que ma famille commencé à
recevoir des insultes on va rappeler de
quoi de quoi êtes vous vous accuse alix
et nabil
lors d'une soirée qui se voit là vous
avez fait une vidéo avec notamment d'une
jeune fille qui serait apparemment
mineur et que vous l'auriez forcer à
vous faire une fellation elle elle
aurait écrit elle aurait pleuré la vidéo
de ce qu'ils nous ont décrit été
extrêmement choquant est vraiment voilà
on les voyait hier tous les deux
apparemment ils auraient vu cette vidéo
déjà il à la question que tout le monde
se pose c'est cette vidéo est ce qu elle
existe à cette vidéo n'existe pas c'est
un vidéo avec ce que vous venez de
décrire ça n'existe pas je n'ai jamais
fait ça de ma vie filmée ou pas filmer
évidemment ça n'existe pas donc
aujourd'hui vous êtes sûr que ça ne
sortira pas parce que si ça existe s'il
existe le moment s'arrêter moi c'est moi
qui ai dit aux blogueurs parce qu'il ya
des blogueurs qui ont dit on à cette
vidéo il m je leur ai dit sortez cette
vidéo je vous en supplie avant j'aurais
dit sortez la cette vidéo je vous le
demande moi parce qu'elle n'existe pas
ensuite j'ai reçu des pressions un peu
de partout où ils sont allés fouiller
dans ma vie en essayant de sortir
d'autres choses comme il n'y a pas de
vidéo en ligne a pas de vidéo il n'y a
pas de victime il n'y a pas de procès il
n'y a pas de plainte parce que la jeune
fille ou là c'est alors juste il ya une
vidéo avec cette jeune fille il n'y a
pas de vidéo avec aucune jeune fils je
leur expliquer ce qui s'est passé vous
avez il ya une jeune fille qui existent
mais peut-être c'est une autre vidéo qui
décrit parce qu'ils ont les clients je
lui expliquer ce qui s'est passé il ya
une 0 vidéo où je fais une agression
sexuelle sur qui que ce soit d'accord il
ya une vidéo à moisn nuit là non il n'y
a pas de vidéo je vous expliquer ce qui
s'est passé j'avais un ancien ami qui
s'appelle sébastien dubois à l'époque
nous dans l'altérité on a souvent on est
on peut on peut se lâcher j'étais fâché
que ces deux personnes et ils voulaient
me nuire très clairement
il allait raconter donc la version que
dit alix elle elle l'a entendu c'est à
dire que lui il allait raconter ça à
nice en disant moi j'ai vu ça sur ille à
gg une vidéo sur ilan en train de faire
c'est en train de faire ça ok il n'a
jamais de montrer il n'a jamais montré
pardon de vidéos où je suis en train
d'agresser une fille alors mineure ou
pas il a neigé c'est parce que hier alix
nous raconter qu'elle était une soue à
la conférence de presse marc élevés
notamment je crois que c'est pour lui
martine le soin qu'elle a vu votre pote
d'autres anciens potes maintenant je
crois c'est seb parle plus trop voilà et
qui lui a dit regarde cette vidéo qui
lui aurait montré ses talents vous à la
conférence de presse pas lui décline
aujourd'hui d'éclat en lui montrant la
vidéo alors je vous expliquer ce qu on a
beaucoup parlé s'il ya une vidéo qui a
été montré s'il ya quelque chose qui a
été montré en aucun cas j'étais en train
d'agresser quelqu'un sexuellement
en aucun cas je le dis hein maintenant
est ce qu'il a montré des story de lui
et moi en train de rigoler avec des avec
des jeunes filles je ne joue pas avec je
fis en tout cas moi je vous le dis je ne
sais pas parce que je peux vous dire un
truc ilan je vous dis tout dit marie
alix va montrer des échanges avec vous
ouais mais tu es un moment voulu dit
cette jeune fille cette jeune fille elle
va très bien je peux même te donner son
numéro tu peux l'appeler parce que c'est
un succès je vous expliquer l'accord
moment donné quand il ya cinq semaines
vous dire on a une vidéo oui moi même je
me pose la question battant quatre
vidéos qu'est-ce qui vient sur cette
vidéo parce que si tout le monde dit
kane vidéo moi je quelqu'un qui fume pas
si bois pas je me suis jamais drogué de
ma vie donc je suis on va dire conscient
de tout ce que j'ai fait dans ma vie
tiens y'a pas une photo souvenir
peut-être que pas du tout je suis très
jeu c'est ce que je fais et moi quand
sébastien m'a dit moi à l'époque mais
sébastien me dit que j'avais la haine
contre toi ilan est-ce qu'il s'est servi
d'eux d'une vidéo peut-être avec des
amis
pour essayer d'appuyer ce qu'il était en
train de dire mais est-ce que vous avez
déjà vous avez déjà fait des soirs avec
lui mais évidemment avec des 50 mais
évidemment un défi mais voilà bon
évidemment mais tout est ton était
consentant il n'y avait pas d' mineurs
tout le monde était content et il n'y
avait pas de mineurs donc c'est toi
quand même et les vidéos de cette façon
vous auriez pu filmer alors c'est pour
ça que je vais me répéter il n'y a pas
de vidéo je n'agresse quelqu'un
sexuellement ça qu'il faut vraiment leur
entrée dans la tête matos celui-ci l'un
des vidéos tout court oui c'est ça mais
des vidéos il y en a cinq vidéos nouveau
train de faire la fête avec des jeunes
filles mais avait mis en boîte de nuit
dans une dot m et bien oui évidemment
voilà donc d'accord mais c'est ça qu'on
va voir mais je veux quand même près je
précise quand même parce que ce que je
suis accusé c'est très grave
je vous explique aujourd'hui moi ça fait
six ans chez dans le milieu donc ce soit
des bacs bugs soient des situations
comme ça j'ai l'habitude de les vivre
c'est mon travail là c'est très grave
mais là ça touche ma famille monsieur
médias que moi j'ai mes parents qui sont
en pleurs qui m'appelle en me disant
regarde le titre avec associé à mon nom
mon père qui me dylan c'est pas normal
de se retrouver en situation comme ça je
dis je le dis je sais pas mais je ne
contrôle pas ces choses là je ne peux
pas contrôler ce que les gens disent mon
père me demande lui parce que ce qui
devient grave c'est que il ya un doute
qui se met dans la tête des gens se
disant est ce que c'est possible que
parce que moi j'ai une étiquette de
chârost c'est un cerveau c'est le
rappeler il a nos chances bien
évidemment visa le chat ouais c'est un
jeu voilà c'est un séducteur qui aime
les femmes j'ai 28 ans
j'aime j'aime les femmes j'ai été un
séducteur dans ma vie aujourd'hui sur sa
d'ailleurs qu'on vous a pris dans ses
émissions exactement tir vu le chevalier
noir voilà oui je suis doué dans la
séduction on va dire non plus dans cette
émission pour ça que je suis venu dans
la séduction
mais bref aujourd'hui c'est pas le sujet
simplement c'est pour ça qu'on appelle
le shar haut c'est une étiquette
aujourd'hui où l'on se dit ah mais bon
c'est un char hausse est possible que
mais en fait il n'y a pas de doute à
avoir parce que moi ce qui m'est
reproché là c'est totalement faux et en
plus c'est infondé parce que il n'y a
pas de victime il n'y a pas de vidéo il
n'y a pas de plainte il n'y a rien du
tout celle que moi j'entends de vivre
même même un cyber harcèlement vous
rendez pas compte il ya des gens qui
disent qu'ils vont violer ma mère mes
frères
il se passe des choses de 2,2 de
fougères qu'on dit des choses deviennent
donc cette vidéo pour vous elle n'existe
pas un niveau l'instant on n'arrive pas
à sortir c'est explique c'est vrai à
venir aujourd'hui gilles car enquêter
ilan parce que cette vidéo aujourd'hui
votre ancien pote ouais c'est serait lui
qui avait la vidéo maintenant il dit
qu'il a plu donc c'est vrai voilà
c'était moi aujourd'hui il dit qu'il a
plu il n'y a pas de vidéo est différent
parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas il ya plus
c'est là que je précise il n'y a pas de
vidéo ou ce qui se dit sur moi existe ça
qu'il faut bien mais en quoi personne
n'a cette vidéo j'ai derrière moi j'ai
essayé toute la journée alors on me dit
qu'il l'a encore montré il ya un mois
quelqu'un aux états unis et puis que
sans doute après vos interventions c'est
ce qu'on dit mais je voulais c'est
répondre et peut-être qu'il aurait été
contraint obligé menacé par vous de
supprimer cette vidéo voilà ce qu'on est
alors mais je vous pose la question je
vous dise qui circulent neigé alors
sébastien on s'est reparlé là ces jours
ci parce qu'il ya cette histoire et que
je les force et m'ont appelé j'avais pas
de contact avec lui depuis mise à part
qu on s'est croisé dans l'émission
depuis au moins je dirais un an ou deux
je joue je vais pas dire de dates exprès
mais enfin précise mme à peu près un
angle donc c'est pas possible par mois
déjà je me lasse persson alors justement
c'est là dessus nabil hier mais m'a dit
que m oui mais au contraire oui mais à
un moment donné si vous commencez à
écouter nabil qui aujourd'hui est
ni des réseaux sonabhy nous a fait
écouter un nom une habile et vous avez
écouté quoi vous a fait écouter un
morceau d'air d'une conversation qui a
été enregistrée à mon insu ils étaient
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux et sur
un plateau télé sous ce qui est
interdite qui a été montée parce que
dans la conversation il montre sa médias
commencent à se renvoyer personne abîmer
jamais de la vie si je sais donc alors
il dit qu'il y avait un tueur devant
chez lui à un tueur ouais c'est bien
dans ce cas il faut aller porter plainte
ne faut pas aller sur des pmp parce que
le problème qu'il ya c'est
qu'aujourd'hui une habile c'est
quelqu'un qui avait un rêve d'enfant de
venir ici il a réalisé son rêve et je
suis très content pour lui ben aussi bon
soit mais par contre faut aller porter
plainte parce que quand il ya une
agression sexuelle sur mineur soit
disant mineures parce que kantigui mais
si on pense aux choses qui sont réelles
quand on voit une vidéo même d'une jeune
fille personne que déterminés c'est le
mineur ou pas chasser dans un premier
temps donc ça c'est une chose comme
qu'il faut relever de deux ça voudrait
dire que la personne qui a filmé cette
agression sexuelle était là en train de
filmer entendu voler à hâter en train
d'agresser une fille sexuellement pas du
tout pas du tout moi c'est possible
comme tu disais cyril il ya peut-être
des vidéos où je rigole avec des filles
alors évidemment pas survivre parce que
en fait ce qui se passe et ce qui est ce
qu'on a raconté hier c'est bon les
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent
c'est donc seb votre aussi un pote qui
aurait montré cette vidéo alix et c'est
lui qui aurait dit regarde la fille est
mineur en plus ya pas de voilà c'est pas
c est lui qui aurait dit voilà un film
dur et même alix nous a dit je ne savais
pas
à l'arrière des rues elle ne dit pas
elle n'a pas sa carte d'identité sur son
front c'est ce que valve a interviewé le
dit pas mais moi je vous explique un
truc aujourd'hui justement sera et des
blogueurs qui ont dit qu'ils allaient
sortir cette vidéo moi je les invite à
la sortir la vidéo je les invite à la
sortir comme ça moi au moins je serai
blanchi parce qu'elle n'existe pas
aujourd'hui alix a demandé l'ouverture
d'une enquête le l'enquêté est ouvert ce
que c'est moi qui allait porter plainte
pour diffamation pour dénonciation
calomnieuse pour cyber harcèlement pour
harcèlement et et
pour incitation à la haine moi j'ai
ouvert cette enquête pour toutes les
personnes qui parlent de moi sur le
réseaux sociaux j'ai des gens qui sont à
dubaï qui se pensent intouchable il ya
des blogueurs qui sont doués qui se
penchent 6e pense intouchable c'est moi
qui se permet tout et n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que les réseaux sociaux on peut pas
faire tout et n'importe quoi et c'est de
plus en plus cadré c'est qu'il ya des
procédures pour leur faire supprimer les
réseaux sociaux à ces gens qui parlent
et qui colportent des rumeurs qui sont
totalement fausses parce que ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que ça cette rumeur
elle existe bien sébastien dubois et il
le reconnaîtra s'il faut il à la
colporter cette rumeur donc c'est seb
c'est votre pote qui avait cette vidéo
et lisa qui a colporté qui a colporté la
rumeur oui ça qui avait évoqué avec
aviesan l'enquêté qui avait cette vidéo
présumés comme il dit voilà qui est
juste pour certains cas sally bott fils
six mois a réagi simon il a dit quoi il
a dit qu'il avait entendu parler lui l'a
jamais vu la vidéo est là moi je connais
votre fils il ya vous avez fait une
erreur il a scellé les missions qu'il a
fait c'est objectif reste du monde il
lui qui l'a jamais vu cette vidéo n'ont
entendu parler alors non parce que moi
alors faut faire attention parce que
j'ai parlé avec simon s'est fait il faut
savoir ici il s'explique sur les réseaux
sociaux
simon n'a jamais entendu parler de cette
histoire ces deux histoires différentes
six mois on avait des différends à
l'époque dans une émission télé parce
que voilà c'est comme ça un ailier
palomino riz pendant qu enseigner pas
son père c'est notre foi non
justement là-dessus joueurs maintenant
il faut savoir une chose c'est que simon
scemama m'a téléphoné à peu près deux
semaines pour s'excuser de tout ce qui
s'était passé dans cette aventure donc
et c'est bien parce qu'il prend la
maturité je suis content pour lui mais
aujourd'hui faut pas tout mélanger et il
ya vous n'allez plus ou moins quand même
à tester cette rumeur alors que ces deux
histoires complètement différente et
j'ai pas si je vous dis j'étais devant
ma télé d'antan écoutait les nuls et un
tiers et je connais mon fils qui m'a dit
qu'il était au courant de cette affaire
bon ben moi j'ai eu au téléphone il m'a
dit qu'il aime encore deux semaines mais
là c'est palace et c'est ce qu'il a dit
sur les réseaux il a ainsi si mais il a
dit qu'il était au courant il est très
dur coup à mélanie qu'il ait jamais vu
allouer l'a dit j'en ai entendu parler
donc voilà si je sais ce qu'il a dit
virtue et moi je vous dis redondant dans
ce d'autant vodka ont été tournés tous
d'accord pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
vidéo il ya que des on dit et ça c'est
absolument insupportable dans un cas
comme dans l'autre on est dans un cas
comme dans l'autre moi mon fils m'a dit
ça est très franchement le cas pour
l'instant pour l'instant et voilà pour
l'instant c'est pas pour lens alors je
vous dis ici voilà dix ans tout le monde
il a tendance à sortir à jamais pour
musa mais il y aura deux vidéos ou
agressent sexuellement qui que ce soit
mineur ou pas jamais je le dis ici dans
tout le monde aujourd'hui il ya des
blogueurs qui sont en train d'essayer de
fouiller dans ma vie parce que quand ils
m'ont fait pression avec cette vidéo
disant on va la sortir on va le sortir
maintenant dean ou des chaussures intel
essaye de t'en sortir comme tu me
j'avais des moyens de m'en sortir je
veux pas dire quoi comment mais j'avais
des moyens de m'en sortir je peux parler
parce que comme c'est en justice
maintenant tu peux pas tout dire sur
quoi donner de l'argent j'avais des
moyens d'en sortir peu importe que ce
soit des dossiers que ce soit des choses
avait moyen de m'en sortir
je n'ai pas fait parce que je suis
innocent donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
passés par la voie de la justice et s'il
doit y avoir une enquête ça avec grand
plaisir parce que justement j'ai j'ai
tous les éléments vous savez comme si
c'est une enquête donc quoi qu'il arrive
la police va essayer de retrouver la
vidéo donc pour vous vous êtes je
voudrais marrant qu'il vous et moi
qu'ils le fassent vous dormez sur vos
deux oreilles sur médine en ce moment
non en ce moment je dors pas trop je
mens mais sinon mais il sait d'ailleurs
que sur la sur cette histoire je vous
explique je suis serein à ce niveau là
d'accord ce que ça n'existe pas
maintenant ce que je trouve comment vous
expliquez que des gens disent l'avoir vu
alors pas parce que à moi je pense
qu'ils mentent pour attester leur
version parce que si t'arrives en disant
quelqu'un m'a dit que mes que tu as pas
de d'éléments pour prouver ça s'est
compliqué alors de dire qu'il ya une
vidéo je les ai vus et je vous explique
qu'une chose qui est très important
c'est que moi quand j'arrive pas cette
vidéo je me suis levé à temps final
quand même atteint 28 ans mais tu sais
ce que tu fais j'ai appelé un blogueur
il m'a donné une version d'une vidéo
j'ai appelé un autre blogueur m a donné
une autre version d'un d'une vidéo et la
version d'alice et est encore différente
moi j'ai fait n'est ce pas possible et
pourquoi elle mentir et pourquoi
l'inventerait ça écoute écoute et pardon
moi je ne suis pas là pour tourner il a
jugé elle ni pour savoir quoi comment
maintenant lâche peu la question que je
me pose c'est que moi personnellement si
je suis victime enfin je suis témoin
pardon d'un viol sur mineur et que la
personne qui est en face de moi à filmer
ça je vais à la police j'attends pas
quatre ans pour aller chez melty sans
dire de nom à la sortie de mon livre
moi c'est ce que je ferais là dit que
c'est ce qu'a de soirée hier qu'ils
allaient porter plainte c'est ce qu'elle
valait c'est ce qu'il faut y aller alors
il faut y aller donc c'est parce que moi
j'ai été par contre moi j'ai vraiment
porté plainte pour diffamation parce que
alix pense que comme tu ne dis pas de
nom je ne peux pas porter plainte pour
diffamation ce qui est totalement faux
quand on peut prouver et moi j'ai de
quoi prouver c'est je le fais je suis
accompagné d'un avocat bien sûr que elle
parle de moi que je suis viré quand on
vous décrit mois si demain elle dit
voilà il ya quelqu'un qui m'a fait un
truc il a des petits yeux
bien sûr il a une poitrine on sait que
c'est donc aujourd'hui moi j'ai des
éléments qui prouvent qu'elle parle de
moi en plus de ça ce qui est très grave
c'est la diffamation à la paix lieu
qu'en public allait lui auprès de mes
employeurs et ça c'est encore plus grave
et ça aussi
je la gelée attaqué pour ça c'est à dire
que elle l'assumé je suis allé voir mes
employés des deux productions pour dire
qu'il a n'a fait ci a fait ça mais les
productions justement à un moment donné
bah quand on va leur poser la question
mais qu'elle parlait forcément c'est moi
parce que voilà il a donc juste j'ai vu
je dit gg je sais qu'ils étaient des
échanges avec alix nous apprend pas mal
ouais quand tu lui dis cette jeune fille
née sur des sur des exigences que vous
avez utilisé bien cette jeune fille
n'était pas mineur et tu peux même
l'appeler elle n'a rascal et c'est
encore une copine à moi
parce que j'ai quelques idées aux je
vais vous expliquer un truc si parce que
il y avait comme comme selma expliquez
moi y avait peut-être une vidéo pas
peut-être une vidéo j'ai dit écoute s'il
ya une vidéo de quelque chose moi je
peux t'assurer que déjà je n'ai jamais
rien fait avec une mineure en l'accord
est premièrement je n'ai jamais forcer
qui que ce soit à faire quoi que ce soit
donc je lui dis parce qu'à un moment
donné il faut aussi savoir quand on se
défend comme on peut quand on est
agressé quelque chose par plusieurs
personnes on se défend si comme on peut
et moi je suis quelqu'un très maladroit
c'est à dire parfois je peux dire ah oui
j'ai dit ça à mon avis non on se
défendre comme on peut maintenant
ça n'existe pas ces sacs en fait il faut
remettre ça n'existe pas et ça ne
sortira jamais lancée à une autre vidéo
que tu as fait tilt poker et peut-être
que c'est une vidéo mais tu vas lui
jamais j'étais avec une mineure jamais
de la vie ni mineur ni forcer ni quoi
que ce soit c'est parce que c'est ça ce
soit mais ne rompt pas mais est ce que
la vidéo qui est décrite elle est
horrible on nous décrit une jeune fille
en piste et c'est grave s'il faut penser
réellement aux filles qui sont
réellement fait violer dans leur vie
parce que là de cole porter ça c'est
dire qu'il ya des filles qui se dit
attends ce médecin il a fait ça mais lui
on ne dit rien emportement inapproprié
avec une jeune fille tu jamais
comportement inapproprié après prête un
char ou prévoient la fin ça veut dire
quoi avec facilement paré dans le
programme alors noté un peu alors non je
ne monte pas mon sexe facilement comme
vous êtes en train de le dire maintenant
mais c'est vrai que je suis pas
quelqu'un de pudique voilà tous les
savoirs mais je monte pas mon sexe
facilement web annonce presque normal
que quelqu'un pays qui a dit et c'est à
dire que si on est en plein dîner à
maintien passe moi le gigot
moment voilà il ya difficilement ces
voix là c'est compliqué je oui mais la
raison qui m'a parlé de comportement un
peu par quatre ouais ouais c'est ce
qu'on nous balade oui mais alors c'est
ce qu'on disait ok mais qui vous a dit
ça alors mais c'est toujours mais
pourquoi la belle feinte mart majorie
mais moi on m'a dit beaucoup de choses
sur ac la réalisation kayhan je sais
dans la réduction au caire alors moi on
m'a dit beaucoup de choses sur beaucoup
de personnes ici mais je me permettrai
pas de planter un jugement public mais
très fragile cynthia way qui a terminé
très fréquenté indique qu'elle a vite
harcelée qu'elle a les moyens cynthia
enrique alors je vais vous expliquer un
truc et je vous arrêtez tout de suite
parce que les histoires avec certaines
filles que vous avez une couse est en
train de cité j'évite depuis un moment
moelleux l'erreur que j'ai peut-être
fait dans ma vie c'est d'avoir fréquenté
des filles puisque c'est mon ex cynthia
c'est mon ex
et les voir peut-être que j'ai fait
c'est que ben j'ai trompé et j'ai blessé
des femmes ça c'est la vérité c'est un
fait c'est à la télé c'est quelque chose
que j'ai toujours assumé
mais en aucun cas je n'ai ni forcer ni
fait quelque chose de grave mais après
je peux comprendre et ça aujourd'hui
avec le recul je n'avais pas quand
j'étais plus jeune mais avec le recul je
peux comprendre qu'une femme blessée qui
se sentent un peu dénigrer peut-être de
la manière dont je l'équité ou où j'ai
trompé il a une rancune contre moi et
qu'elle dise ce genre de choses et ça il
a donné aujourd'hui tête à une telle
motion ou pas
va falloir regarder les princes de
l'amour pour savoir un oui je d'accord à
vous répondre à ces questions pour être
honnête ça parfois quand vous avez
toujours jouer une question d'ordre
non vous avez toujours publiquement de
votre image de séducteur voire de
mauvais garçons avec les filles on vous
appelle il ya le chat où vous l'avez dit
est-ce que suite à ces accusations
qu'elle soit vraie ou fausse vous allez
changer la manière dont vous vous
comportez dans l'émission et hors
antenne alors je vous explique qu'il
n'ya pas une question de changer parce
qu'encore une fois la personne que je
suis j'ai toujours assumé et c'est ce
qui fait mon personnage maintenant c'est
vrai que dans la dernière aventure que
j'ai fait j'ai évolué jeu je deviens un
autre homme parce que j'ai rencontré des
personnes dans ma vie qui m'ont fait
évoluer comme tout le monde aujourd'hui
j'ai 28 ans je suis plus le même que
quand j'avais 23 ans forcément on a tous
fait des erreurs on a tout fait pour moi
j'ai
bien véhicules et mai et il a juste pour
résumer la vidéo pour vous n'existe pas
donc la vidéo n'existe pas elle n'existe
pas vous n'avez jamais envoyé de tueur
un habit banon donc si vous êtes
tranquille avec ça je suis tranquille
mais je suis plus que tranquille bon
enfin vraiment donné faut envoyer un
tueur quoi c'est
un bon carnet d'adressés voudrait dire
je t'en sais je n'ai jamais envoyé de
tueurs à qui que ce soit d'ailleurs